the engine behind me is Babbage's
Difference Engine number two designed by
Charles Babbage an English mathematician
who is also known as the first computer
pioneer Beverage designed this machine
between 1847 and 18-49 Babbage as we
know did not succeed in completing any
of his own engines in in their entirety
so there is no complete Babbage engine
this is the first physical realization
of any of Babbage's complete designs in
the metal the engine itself weighs 5
tons it consists of 8,000 parts made of
bronze cast iron and steel and it
measures 11 foot long and eight foot
high it's operated by cranking a handle
what it does is it calculates and
tabulates the value of any seventh order
polynomial class of mathematical
expressions 231 decimal places
it not only calculates that with
unerring accuracy it also prints an
inked hard copy as a record of the
results and also produces what I call
stereotyped plates that is it impresses
the results in soft material plaster in
this instance so that you can make a
printing plate automatically and the
purpose of all this was to eliminate the
risk of human error in the calculation
and production of printed mathematical
tables the machine is operated by
cranking this handle so you turn this
handle and each cycle of the engine the
machine produces one result so you just
keep cranking you set the initial
conditions up on the figure wheels on
the numbered wheels you turn the handle
what happens when you turn the handle is
it drives this cam stack and if you like
this is the microprogram
this is the device that orchestrates all
the internal motions of the machine to
get it to form the repeated additions
that are needed for the method of
differences which is the principle it is
using so you turn the handle it terms
these cam stacks the 28 separate cams
and that is what determines the internal
timing and the orchestration of all the
mechanical movements of the whole
machine so that's like the guts of the
machine the internal microprogram what
the machine does is it adds a 31 digit
number on one column and it progresses
through the Machine adding from column
to column to column and the tabular
value the result ends up in the very
last column 31 digits so you crank the
handle
each cycle of the engine that's four
turns the handle each cycle of the
engine produces the next result on this
column so the end process the end
product of that whole process is a 31
digit number on this column so we take
the 31 digit result from the end of the
machine at the end of the cycle and it
is automatically transferred to this
apparatus which is the output apparatus
it does two things it prints on hardcopy
in Inked hardcopy a 31 digit result
that's a checking copy so that you know
actually what you've calculated at the
same time it impresses results on soft
material in these trays so inside there
they are called things called
stereotyped punches which are number
wheels which are lowered into the tray
the tray then moves it lowers again and
so the lines build up firstly it's on
display here at the Computer History
Museum for one year it's on loan from
the owner of the machine which is Nathan
Myhrvold who commissioned the machine he
paid for the machine to be built and so
it's here for a year and then it goes
into his private collection what we will
do with it is demonstrate it four people
will work on it's a research machine so
it'll be adjusted and worked on we'll
get experience about how the thing
operates and also part of the reason now
that it is here and it does work and we
have for the first time a Babbage engine
that is to do some research and say was
it a practical proposition if babies had
one could they have successfully
produced tables Babbage was not an
impractical dreamer this machine works
as he intended to work but was the
entire enterprise of using the
infallibility of machinery to produce
printed tables was it realistic could it
have been done and for the first time in
history we were in a position to
actually answer that question
you